diabetes is a metabolic disease in which
the body cannot produce enough insulin
thus resulting in a high blood sugar
level influen and glucagon are two
molecules that work opposite each other
to keep the body's blood sugar level at
a constant safe level insulin induces
the body to take glucose out of the
bloodstream and start thus lowering
blood sugar levels while glucagon causes
the liver to release stored glucose from
cells into the blood thus raising blood
sugar levels the synthesis of insulin
begins with a precursor pre pro insulin
which is produced in the beta cells of
the pancreas it is converted to pro
insulin and then mature insulin glucagon
is produced in the pancreatic alpha
cells the insulin signaling pathway
begins in an insulin molecule binds to a
tyrosine kinase insulin receptor this
activates it in causes dimerization then
one of the many signal transduction
proteins causes a vesicle of glucose
transporters to bind to the cell
membrane thus allowing glucose to move
out out of the blood stream into the
cell the glucagon signaling pathway
starts with the liver where the glucose
is stored in the form of the
polysaccharide glycogen glucagon begins
with the pathway by binding to a special
approaching receptor called the
g-protein coupled receptor or GPCR this
activates a change in the structure
which leads to the activation of
g-protein which has three subunits alpha
beta and gamma however when the G
protein binds to the GPCR the gdp
molecule that was on the Alpha subunit
is substituted with a higher energy gtp
molecule which causes the alpha subunit
to detach the alpha subunit then
activates next enzyme in the Cascade
adenylyl cyclase which produces cyclic
AMP ER camp which then triggers a
cascade that results in glycogen being
broken down into glucose and transported
out of the cell type 1 diabetes can be
hereditary but it can also be caused by
environmental factors like food toxins
or viral infections it usually develops
during winter as diseases like mumps and
rubella are more prevalent for example
congenital rubella is associate with
beta cell destruction type 2 diabetes
can be hereditary beta can also develop
when a person is overweight or not
exercising regularly